foreign
[Music]
Kill Grill the sponsors of this next
segment have been part of the Las Vegas
Community since 1943. they've been
attracting booties and families from
across the country and I stopped by for
a behind the scenes look at this
legendary barbecue joint welcome to John
Mull's meats and roadkill Grill the
number one barbecue place in Nevada
number six in the country and this place
has one incredible backstory
foreign
thanks for coming I'd appreciate you
guys stopping by well Chuck thanks for
having us man because I gotta tell you
I'm a huge fan of your Meats well I
appreciate it it's so good and it's
funny I didn't see you here last week I
see I'm a fan I'm a fan but let's let
the backstory your grandfather opens
it's 1943. why this area why this spot
80 some years ago it was cheap man
that's why
no there was there was water and he had
an abundance of food so that's why he
opened it up right here as far as his
logic behind moving out here he knew
that the city was actually going to grow
he didn't know how long it was going to
take but he figured if you put it out
far enough he wouldn't have to move over
you know a short period of time Chuck
what do we got here that's a beef rib
beef rib this is a brontosaurus Rift
and you'll see why when we get this
thing out oh my gosh that thing is huge
so we smoked this for about 16 hours
and after we get it to about 165 degrees
we'll wrap it we'll wrap it in this
round paper and then we'll wrap it in
the Saran Wrap and it helps it to sweat
once it reaches 185 we'll pull it off
put it in that little warmer right there
and just let it sweat until it's ready
to go man you've never had one of these
no I'll give you a piece of this man
can you tell me what you think of that
you want a wood sauce without sauce I'll
go without sauce all right
you don't even need tea to eat this it
melts on your tongue that's crazy yeah
it's just like eating butter man
strawberry sauce
I'm gonna make the cameraman hungry man
that's right that sauce gives this an
extra punch I love it
so this is brown
[Music]
another rub that we make up exclusively
for this these are the rubs that you can
buy you can buy these rubs right here
and then this is just honey
it's honey and brown sugar on your
birthday yeah man this is what you call
uh meat candy baby try that now tell me
if that isn't totally different
it's like eating candy in it that's bomb
dude get out of here with this that's
crazy stuff it is
[Music]
Chuck what are you doing here freshly
slicing beef tri-tip beef tri-tip so
this Cooks about about three hours right
and it kind of goes low and slow it's
one of the one of the fastest meats that
we cook though and it's not really heavy
smoke it's more of a light smoke with
more of a seasoned flavor than anything
else now that is fresh tri-tip right
there
oh my God
that is moist that is flavorful
tender and tasty certainly there's two
teas is actually one of your meat right
tender and tasty that's right man
let's go try to a little steam coming up
but you see it
now it's not just Meats the roadkill
Grill is also known for their sides
including their award-winning mac and
cheese
how many different cheeses we got five
different cheeses five cheeses in your
mac and cheese
Chuck this day has been spectacular
thank you so much for having us well I
appreciate you man do you have a room
that I can go take a nap in because I am
so full I need to nap this off for sure
John Mull's meats and roadkill Grill is
located at 3738 Tom Tom Boulevard call
702-645-1200 or visit
johnmollsmeetcompany.com and check out
this special offer mentioned Las Vegas
now and you'll receive complimentary
cobbler dessert which is to die for it
all looks so good I need that mac and
cheese in my life